les cosmonautes se prépare à quitter la
station spatiale les modules russes s'en
détache applaudissements dans la salle
de contrôle
cette vidéo satirique de l'agent
spatiale russe résume la position
étrange dans laquelle se trouvent
actuellement les 7 octobre la station
disons que l'ambiance paul géopolitique
et a plombé l'ambiance scientifique qui
règne dans la station on voit bien qu'il
ya des extensions depuis dix jours c'est
le directeur d'al agences spatiales
russe lui-même qui mène la tacc youtube
et rostov si les américains persistent
nous allons remettre en question
l'existence même de la station spatiale
navigation sans nous la station ne peut
ni se déplacer ni fonctionner
normalement
dimitri rogozine est un habitué des
polémiques il vient d'ailleurs de quelle
fille et d'imbécile un astronaute
américain critique du président poutine
la réalité c'est que à ce moment
[Musique]
a réussi
mais le départ des russes aussi
politique soit ils n'annoncent rien de
bon on pourrait éventuellement
continuer de faire opérer l'association
sans la russie si la russie décidé
unilatéralement qu'elle ne participe
plus mais ça prendrait le temps
la compagnie spacek ce qui assure
maintenant l'essentiel du transport des
passagers vers la station quoi qu'elle
pourrait remplacer les russes presque à
pied levé
mais dans les faits tout la station et
le flux de 30 ans de partage
technologique et de collaboration pour
piloter la station ça prend des russes
pour justement corps et faire les
corrections d'altitude mais l'énergie
l'électricité nécessaire pour faire ça
elle provient du module américain donc
c'est interconnectés
en parallèle les européens ont interdit
l'accès de leur centre spatial ou russes
moscou essaie de lancer des satellites
étrangers et dans un mois on se demande
si le vol de retour de l'américain mark
wendel aurait lieu comme prévu dans une
capsule soyouz et ça fait comme déjà un
an qu'il est dans la station on arrive
un petit peu à la durée maximale est ce
qu'on est capable de le prolonger
quelques mois le temps d'envoyer une
cape suspect 6 c'est à voir marc garneau
qui étaient à bord de la station en
novembre 2000 condamne les actions de la
russie mais espère que la station
spatiale survivre à cette crise j'ai
tellement il est
tellement important
on voudrait tous que ça demeure ni parti
ou une seule planète qui n'est pas
contestée où on est capable de coopérer
de travail à 100 ici normand grondin
radio canada montréal
[Musique]